congratulations to all the winners here
tonight you followed your passion and
you worked hard and now you're in
Hollywood winning an award from the
Academy the Academy nicely done guys
having grown up in a multicultural
household
I know exposure to other cultures can
make one's life richer there were 93
entries in this category this year and
I'm honored to announce the winning
films the winning films are everything
will be OK by Patrick full rat from the
film Academy Veen in Austria a seemingly
a seemingly routine visit between a
divorced father and his eight-year-old
daughter turns into a fateful journey
fidelity by ill Kersh attack from
Hamburg Media School in Germany
a woman in his in Istanbul gives shelter
to a political activist and creates a
precarious situation by refusing to
cooperate with the police and the last
will by Dustin Losier from the film
academy Baden Gutenberg in Germany to
fulfill his mother's will
a young man must visit his
institutionalized father who killed his
brother years earlier